[拍手]
これからどこへ向かうのか何のために
生きるのか
働くとは何か
喜びとは何かこれから自分は何になって
いくのかその
答えを求めて歩んできた今まででし
た友辻広志です私は
淡路島で生まれ育ちました
今現在は地元の南あわじ市でオカリナ公募
を営んでおります学生時代は勉強も
スポーツも特に光るところがなく特に音楽
と数学が苦手でした今でも音楽音符恐怖症
です
高校在学中の時に呼んだ本の影響で
新選組になりたいと思いましたが
求人票には新選組はありませんでしたそこ
で
仕方なく
包丁が
刀のように見えてかっこいいという理由
だけで
老舗の
厳しいそしてへの就職を決めます
淡路島を離れ先輩方と同じ
寮に住み24時間四六時中先輩方のパシリ
として走り回りましたいざ
働き出すとお寿司の数も読めない先輩の
顔色も読めない
大将の腕力もかわせない
まともに真っ正面からぶち当たっていく
ような不器用な18歳でした
で真面目が上のね空回りをしてしまい
やがてうつになってしまいましたで働け
なくなりこの悩みを母に伝えると私の未来
を変えてくれる最高の言葉を伝えてくれ
ました
辛い時は本を読みなさい
最高の言葉ですね後にこの時の感謝を母に
伝えますと
そんなこと言ったっけとのことでした感謝
しています
それから日本一切切れる包丁を目指して私
が研いでますと先輩がこう言いましたお前
な
そんな
技術ばっかり磨こうとしたじゃないか
そんなことはない40年も同じことやり
続けたら誰だってそれなりのことができる
職人にはなれるせやけどどうやって人に
喜ばれる人間になるのかそのことを考え
んかったらお前の成長はそれまでや
職人にはなるな
商売人になれもっと人のことや世の中の
ことを学べそう言ってくれました
この言葉はオカリナ職人となった今も
とても考えさせられている言葉です
それから私は自分を変えてくれるような本
はないかと
探し読み漁りました
経験を広げるために様々な飲食店へ
食べ歩きやがて洋食への
興味が湧いてきて3年半勤めた寿司店を
退職することに決めました
退職後最初に働き出したのはイタリア料理
店のオープニングスタッフとなりまだ
刺身包丁を振り回してましたで
それから1年後にファンとして通い続けた
大好きなフランス料理店ビストロで働ける
チャンスがやってきました
ですが18歳からの鬱症状と
憧れのお店で働けるというプレッシャー
からだんだんもう働けなくなり不眠症に
なって2日間連続で第1国をしてしまい
ました
政府に次やったらもうないからなと言わせ
てしまいました
電話越しに本当に情けなく申し訳なく
泣き崩れ
役に立たない人間であることを詫びて料理
の道を止めることにしました
シェフに直接挨拶に行った時シェフは強く
優しくこう言ってくれました10年後の
智地君がどんな人間になっとるのか
楽しみにしとるで待っとるからな
ですがこの当時の私はまだそのシェフの
温かい心も受け取るほどの力がありません
でしたそれからほんまに
ズタボロになりました
真面目にやってきてうまくいかない自分だ
からもう真面目なんてクソくらいだと思い
ましたもうやけくそです行く当てもなく
淡路島に帰って
兄が勤めるコンビニで夜勤させてもらい
ながら学生ぶりに遊びにふけました
久々に会う同級生たちは
昨日に大人の道を歩んでいました今まで
素晴らしいお店で修行してきた私なのに
本当に悔しい思いでいっぱいでした
昼間もアルバイトをしてお金を貯めて
自分のことを全く知らない場所で新しい
自分になって生きていこうと何を血迷った
のか東京の
芸能事務所へ行くことにしました
母は私を引き止めようとしましたが
可愛い子には旅をさせろと言って私は家を
出て行きました
東京に行きますと事務所のレッスンで演技
の本気の役者さんたちが熱演をしており
ましたそれを見てさすがに私も何しに来た
んやろここに行って思いましたですがもう
ね東京来てしまってますなのでまあ今まで
真面目にやってきたからダメになったんか
なじゃあ真面目な自分が嫌いなことをやっ
てみようということでパチンコ店で
アルバイトを始めたり人の紹介で
有名人たちが集まる特殊なバーでお酒も
あまり飲めないのにバーテンダーしてみ
たりしました東京に来たことでそういった
同じような世代で夢を求めてやってきた
仲間たちと出会いそしてまち普通にね
遊び歩いてるとそこその辺で寝てる方達も
いたりですね
バー行くと
日本東京世界中
活躍してるような業界の一流トップの
方たちと出会うことがあり何だこの世界は
と思いました衝撃動きました
いろんな人生あって世界もあって
答えなんか何もない自分もじゃあこれでも
いいんじゃないかなで少しずつ
覚えてくるようになりました東京で学んだ
のは開き直りという力です
そして
そんな時だんだん調子付いてきたんです
けどもそんな時に
父がですね
病に倒れてしまってもう先が長くないと
母から連絡が来て私は再度淡路島に帰る
ことにしました
父は私が高校を卒業あたりから職場と
うまくいかなくなって
退職をしてそのまま無職を8年間続けてき
たような父でした
で私が東京に出てからようやく職場が
見つかって楽しそうに働き出した矢先の病
でし
たしばらくして
父はこの世から去りました
最後の最後までわしはいつ働けるのかなと
呑気に笑っているような父でし
た働きたくても
働けないという人がいることを知りました
いつかはみんなとも必ずさよならの時が
来ることも知りました
今まで
ろくに働かずにどうしようもない親父やな
と思ってた父でしたが同じ8年間
父もつらかったんだろうなと思うように
なりました
それから私は自分を
否定すること最後にね父が残してくれたの
は自分自身の存在のありがたさでした
そのおかげで私はもう自分を否定してきた
今までだったんですけど
否定することを一切やめるようになりまし
た
さよならの寂しさも
過去への未練も全くなくすべてのことは
運命のことであるだから天に任せてこれ
から自分が行うことだけがこれからの自分
の人生を作ると思いました
そして今まで呼んできたたくさんの本たち
と出会いと学び
常識も自由に超えてオリジナルのひろしを
歩んでみようと思いました
26歳の時です
淡路島に帰ってきて
直後の私はですね
無職無一文
車の免許も失効しているといった
散々な状態でした今笑いながら言ってます
けどね
散々な状態でした
で
片道1時間半分壊れた自転車に乗って
アルバイトへ帰りました
ブレーキもライトも壊れてて後ろから車に
煽られてクラクション鳴らされますし
おまけにゆきまで降ってきますしもう本当
に
覚えとけよって言いながら車が去っていく
ような
悔しさでした
ですがアルバイトを続けていくとやがて
料理長に抜擢されるようになって出会いが
あって
料理長になりました
自分を信じた私は
飲食店では珍しい
エンターテイメントを取り入れたサービス
を行ったり
毎朝街のゴミ拾いをしたりそして心に
湧き上がってくる今までたくさん読んでき
た本のおかげで湧き上がってくる言葉を神
に書いてレジの前に並べてどうぞご自由に
お取りくださいとしてそしてお祝いの作品
を書いてお客様にプレゼントしたりする
ようになりました
やがて独立の思いが高まり
刀でも
包丁でもなく筆を持つことにしました
あなたの目を見て感じたもので言葉を書き
ます1枚1円からのお気持ちでそう書いた
看板を立てて
父の形見の着物を着て
即興で独学の言葉を書き始めました
真夏も冬も人の行き交う中でただ一人
じっと座って人の行動や言葉を
観察して集中してそして人生について考え
続けました
すると人は皆それぞれ自分の使う言葉の
通りに自分の人生を作って生きていると
いうことに気がつきましたやがて書いて
くださいという方々が列になり全国各地へ
呼ばれるようになって10年間で5万人
以上の方々に書かせていただくことができ
ました
今まで私が自分を否定してきたのは
人の目から見た評価で自分を見てきたから
でした
ですがこのつらかったことがその後役に
立ちます
人の目を気にしすぎてしまう私のこの
点を使って人の心を感じ取る能力にして
それを
プラスの視点で言葉にして人に書き下ろす
そうやってマイナスをプラスに変換して
言葉を書いてきました
自分のことを知って受け入れていくことは
とても苦しいことだとは思いますですが
痛みを知るからこそ痛みのことが分かり
ます
それと同じで
短所というのは決してなくしてしまう
しまわなきゃいけないようなもんじゃなく
てそれがあるからこそ
唯一無二の自分で荒れているというほどに
人生においての素晴らしい
キーポイントだとここでお伝えしたいです
その
キーワードとして使える言葉私だからこそ
という言葉があります
私だからこそと言って
心の向きを今まで私なんてと突き刺さって
たこの私向きのこの
矢印を私だからこそと言った瞬間外向きに
向いてですね私だからこそできることが
ある私だからこそみんなが親切にして
くれる私だからこそあの人の気持ちが
わかってあげられるそんな風に
視野が広い世界へ向いて自分だけの唯一
無二の道を歩める
羽が
モデル
羽を持つことができます
さて多くの方に言葉を書かせていただいた
おかげで友人にも恵まれました
友人がオカリナという小さな手に収まる
サイズの
楽器を持っていたので私も言葉かけの間に
持ち歩いて拭いてると楽しいかなっていう
気軽な気持ちで吹き始めました
ですが私はゼロか100しかないぐらいの
極端な性格なので土からこの楽器ができて
るっていうのを知った時になんか不思議な
魅力に引き込まれて夢中になってしまい
ました仕事もせずに吹いてたっていうのは
内緒ですねはいでそれから
このね手に収まるサイズで
ですが私ねあの音符恐怖症なんですいまだ
に楽譜も読めてませんなので音楽家には
なれないですねだからこその支店の変換を
行いました今まで料理
筆文字ってやってきた手仕事が得意なので
じゃあこれ年度からできてるんだったら
やってみたらいいかもしれないと思って私
向いてるかもと思って作ってみました
初めて作ったばかりなねまず最初は音も出
ませんし
潰れて気絶も入ってますし
完全に失敗でしたでも1万回でも
失敗してみたら
必ず
成功できると思いました
この手に収まるサイズのたまたまこれ
淡路島の形をしてましたでこれを見てこれ
をふるさと淡路島の土を使ってそして
江戸時代から300年以上続いてきた
伝統のいぶし瓦のいぶし銀に仕立て上げて
そしてこれを淡路島の新名物として発展さ
せていくことはできないかということに
とても大きなやりがいと使命を感じました
300年以上残り続けて今ね活躍し続けて
いるのがピアノという楽器ありますけども
があったりですね
ストラディバリウス」っていう300年
経っても現役で活躍してるバイオリンが
あったり
それと同じようにはいかないかもしれませ
んが300年瓦で残っていく素材ですので
私はこのオカリナに300年の未来を見て
います
それから私は
筆文字の仕事を一旦
置いといてオカリナの研究だけをすること
にしました
よく私をね今までやってきたことを変えて
新しく
新しいことにチャレンジしていくことに怖
さや未練はないんですかないんですかと
聞かれますですがもともと無職も一問です
そしてエクストにもなったことありますな
ので
失ってしまうことの怖さよりもこれからに
始まっていくことの楽しみの方が勝ってい
て
挑戦している時皆さん挑戦とよく使います
けど
夢中になってるっていう間は
挑戦してるっていう気持ちすらありません
そして今までの経験すべてが
成長へ繋がり続けるなので今とこれからが
与えられている自分の人生があることが
ありがたくて
楽しみでしかないという状態です
さて
オカリナをね作る音楽の知識は
実際に作ってみてからそれからオカリナの
プロ奏者さんたちに出会うことで
アドバイスを頂いて成長させてもらえる
ことができましたおかげさまで
淡路島のオカリナは全国に広まり
約11ヶ月ご予約のお待ちをいただくほど
のオカリナとなりましたありがとうござい
ます
そして使命を叶えるべくオカリナ島
プロジェクトという
淡路島に新しい文化を作っていく
活動を仲間たちとスタートさせました
それはオカリナの作り方をまず教えてその
作りみんなが作ったオカリナを
新しくお金の引きたいという方に
渡して教えたりそして子供たちと一緒に
拭いたりしながら
未来の独立して働けるオカリナ制作者や
オカリナ演奏家そして音楽講師
を増やしていくそして多くの愛好家を
増やしていくという活動です
私が
今まで
歩んできた道はですね
探してきた道それは
歩き続けることの中にありました
ゼロからでも1万でも
挑戦し続けてそして
諦めないことですね
そして今まで歩き続けてきたことで自由に
方向転換して
きたことそして可能性を信じて言葉を私だ
からこそと変えて今の自分に出会いました
この場にも恵まれました
最後に
紆余曲折の私の歩みから言えるメッセージ
を皆さんにお伝えしたいと思いますすごく
シンプルです
オカリナを知るまでは
オカリナの喜びを知らなかったのです
これは全てのことにおいて言えます
こうしなきゃいけないということは何も
ありませんだからこそ
素晴らしい出会いを
ご清聴いただきましてありがとうござい
まし
[拍手]